might be the one I think this is a
moment tle you're a amazing give
different angles and like let's take
pics is also what's another move I posy
it's it's really good look better than
the rendering always happy to be at the
Met I always love going to the met I
feel like the some of the most fun Parts
about going is that before it happens
and we like
discuss our Vibes together body in this
is insane Z thought you did fit I just
think the sleeves are such a moment I'm
going with Marc Jacobs and I felt that
he would be a great Visionary for
something that felt Carl These Boots are
so good the boots are pretty wild they
are like a Marc Jacobs classic they're
very tall and they can get kind of
wobbly but they're great um and they're
just so sick but I'm already 5'11 so I
think I'm about 67 literally the tallest
person in the room I don't know okay I'm
going to finish my nails okay thank you
I love it love you K love you